en france l'actualité c'est cette hausse
des prix de l'énergie avec un tarif à la
pompe qui a poussé le gouvernement à
fournir 100 euros aux personnes touchant
moins de 2000 euros par mois et
l'inflation et général faisant craindre
une perte très important du pouvoir
d'achat des français c'est entre autres
ce qui a convaincu les gilet jaune de
redonner un nouveau souffle à leur
mouvement ils ont appelé à de nouveaux
rassemblements dont cette manifestation
à paris où l'on joint tout de suite
entre reporter nadège abderrazak
mon goana des dollars qu'elle est non
mais en fait tu es loin
[Musique]
écoutez ami a pu entendre et est
derrière moi l'ambiance est plutôt
festive et bon enfant se situe boulevard
voltaire ain pour le moment et la
manifestation se déroule bien ont dans
le calme alors vous l'avez tir nouvelle
mobilisation des jets les jeunes courent
à protester contre la hausse du prix des
énergies hausse du prix du carburant la
mise en place de cette indemnité
inflation de 100 euros annoncés cette
semaine par jean castex et n'y change
rien les chez les jeunes estiment qu'il
s'agit d'une broutille d'une mesure
était qui ne servira pas à
combler leurs difficultés financières je
vous propose d'écouter certains
manifestants
le chèque de 100 euros c'est juste pour
endormir les gens parce que si vous
divisez 100 euros par part 12 mois ça
fait quoi 8 euros au bout de votre plein
donc c'est pas c'est pas suffisant 100
euros vous retirer les taxes ça veut
dire qu'on à 39 euros sur une année ma
décomptés par jour seuls s'affaisser des
miettes et puis tu fasses on peut
arrêter de se [ __ ] de notre gueule
c'est pas les 100 euros qui vont changer
quoi que ce soit dans la vie des gens ce
chèque c'est une énorme connerie c'est
une escroquerie c'est un truc politique
ça s'est il est en campagne électorale
sans le dire voilà on va tout faire pour
l'empêcher de gagner ça fait le but là
le prochain projet notre projet à nous
puisque l'huile à des projets c'est de
l'empêcher de gagner la prochaine
élection et comme chaque samedi comme à
chaque manifestation de gilet jaune gros
dispositif de police mis en place pour
ce rassemblement aujourd'hui alors vous
le voyez derrière mme en a plusieurs
dizaines d' équipes de gendarmerie et de
crs mobilisés pour assurer le maintien
de l'ordre de cette manifestation
l'objectif en de la préfecture de police
de paris c'est d'éviter tout débordement
d'éviter toute image de violence comme
on a pu le voir au début du mouvement il
n'y a à peu près trois ans l'objectif
c'est évidemment et d'éviter de revoir
ces images on se souvient que des
milliers de gilet jaune avaient été
blessés certains d'entre eux ont été
mutilés des images qui en ferait tâche à
quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle et d'une éventuelle
candidature d' emmanuel macron
[Applaudissements]